so I'm going to launch right into this
panel just echo a few of Griff's
sentiments I mean we're here to talk
about local solutions and and learn from
them and we have an excellent panel with
us here today to do that I I think it
goes without saying that what we're
trying to achieve here is requires
systemic change that energy is an energy
use requires a whole host of different
players in in a community in a state to
to come together and and and develop
these solutions and I think the members
of our panel here today will will speak
to that we have with us to my immediate
left Keith whelks who is Pennsylvania's
deputy state treasurer for fiscal
operations next to him oh sorry next to
him I'm glad I looked Dorian Dale who is
the energy director and sustainability
officer in Babylon New York and then
George Jung who is the director of
policy with the Vermont Public Service
Board I happen to have a benefit of
knowing knowing Dorian the best and I'll
just make one add a comment which is I
made my own attempt this past year to
put a high-efficiency boiler in my co-op
in brooklyn new york it only took me a
year and three months to get my co-op
board to approve me putting a hole in
the roof about the size of Dorian's
thermos so that the water vapor could
could be properly ducted and not ducted
into a shared chimney and and so I have
one of two aspirations either to move to
Babylon New York or or learn from our
panel today about
to how to make these sorts of systemic
changes which require co-op boards and
contractors and financers and policy
makers to come together so with that why
did I turn it over first to Keith and
thank you oh thanks thought I was going
last but I'm happens no it's fine I
wasn't going to be working on my remarks
during the first presenters remarkably
enough they're actually complete well
thank you very much I may have
Pennsylvania Treasury for inviting us to
participate we're honored to be here
excited it's a great opportunity I was
here for much of this morning's panel
and it was a great launch pad eject
kickoff I want to start by engaging in
the time-honored practice of lowering
expectations I'm always I'm always a
little skeptical and a lot terrified
when I'm introduced on a best practices
panel number one it sounds egotistical
but actually more troubling is I'm
always certain there's some Joker in the
audience who says after hearing my
remarks you know that's not even a good
practice what I'm doing is far better
and so if I can I'm going to modify the
title i'm going to talk about pretty
good practices let's hope let me start
by doing a little positioning I'm from
the Pennsylvania Treasury Department
that means that we are in some ways and
in some very significant ways quite
distinct from most of the kinds of
organizations and entities that talk
about energy efficiency and providing
support for energy efficiency we are in
a sense not a program agency okay it's a
very important thing to get on the table
that means that we don't have
appropriated funds from our legislature
from the Pennsylvania General Assembly
that are given to us to carry out
programmatic activities with particular
objectives whether those objectives are
to support energy conservation or
anything else that's not what we do we
are an investor we are essentially a
quasi private party investor entrusted
with responsibility of managing the
Commonwealth's assets and generating
return from those assets for as long as
we have them
and they aren't needed by other agencies
to make payments we have a statutory
standard that's imposed upon us when we
manage those monies it's the prudent
person standard most fiduciaries are
familiar with it and it essentially in
short obligates us to generate a
reasonable rate of return on any monies
that we hold commencer with the risk
associated with the investment class
into which we place those dollars so
everything I talked about today that
we've done is in the spirit of being a
prudent investor and the bottom line for
this discussion is that that means that
we can't simply get involved in a
project because we like the objectives
that project you can simply support an
energy-efficiency kind of initiative
because we think the end result reduce
consumption of fossil fuels is a good
result it may very well be a good result
but that's not a good result that has
any bearing on our decision-making so
that's a an important first thing to
talk about I'm going to try and run
through fairly quickly a program we're
involved in that we're invested in to
remain you know faithful to my theme
that were invested in in Pennsylvania
called the health program home energy
loan program it's a program that we
created or was created about five years
ago Bob Casey was elected treasurer i
joined the office in 2005 Bob Casey told
his staff look we have a prudent person
responsibility so I want you guys to go
out and find investments they're going
to do well for the Commonwealth but I
also wanted to find investments that at
the same time are going to do good for
the people of the Commonwealth in ways
that you could based on my particular
background I was interested in
environmental environmentally themed
investment opportunities and I after
talking to lots of people became
convinced that there had to be some way
that we as Treasury could invest in
energy efficiency plays that were
sufficiently well designed that they
would generate a return that would both
repay our investment create a yield to
us and still be worthwhile to the person
who actually took them up in ensure if
you will to borrow a term from from
Hollywood where if you can describe a
movie in 25 words or less which is
called high concept you can get your
movie made if it takes you 26 words to
describe what your movies about
you can't get funding for it so our high
concept was we wanted the amount of
money that a homeowner saved from
implementing an energy efficiency
project each month to be roughly the
same as the cost of paying off the loan
for that energy efficiency project if
they could break even on a loan and then
have all returned after the lowest paid
off that sounded like a good place for
us to be investing and so that's what we
tried to do spend a lot of time looking
for someone who might have some thoughts
on how we could do that what we knew was
that we needed a partner both because we
didn't know anything about this space
and and because so I already have more
than two boats not the right needed and
because we don't do retail investing and
also because we have to have a partner
we're an investor or not a program
agency and here's where we got
particularly lucky we found a firm a
consumer lender in Allentown
Pennsylvania that had been doing energy
lending for 12 or 15 years and they
understood what the secret of success in
this field was people who have paid
attention to this area probably know
that there have been many if conceivably
dozens of what I would characterize as
bank based loan programs low and support
programs for energy efficiency projects
that have been created over the past
several decades very few of them have
succeeded but if you have gotten any
traction and that's because we believe
that's because most energy efficiency
loans and I drop a footnote here that
we're going to start talking if I have
time to discuss other kinds but most
energy efficiency loans even today are
what we consider to be or what we would
call reactive that is to say that most
of these loads for home improvements are
taken out by someone whose furnace is
broken down on februari third and is
looking at zero degree days for the next
week or two and wants to get a new
furnace in place as rapidly as possible
okay it's not someone who's going to
spend a lot of time trying to figure out
what's the most efficient way to do that
if it's someone who goes to a bank
they're not going to be thinking about
energy efficiency to all they're going
to be getting the loan
and then hiring a contractor to put
improving it so if you want to do energy
efficiency you have to sell that product
and that that sale occurs with the
contractor so one of the first keys that
we understood and was actually taught to
us was that having contractors who are
committed to an energy efficiency
program both because they knew it
believed in it and also because they had
an incentive associated with selling
that program were a key ingredient to
success the investment partner we worked
with happen to be working that way firm
called AFC first financial they had when
we first engage with him about 500
contractors that they had created into a
network they had trained them in these
techniques they had sort of validated
them as competent professional and
ethical and they were working through
them these contractors clearly were
interested in simplicity they're
interested in a product that could sell
rapidly they're interested in something
that a homeowner could understand easily
and they're interested in financing
approvals that could be generated
quickly enough that the homeowner would
say yeah let's go ahead and do that so
we entered into a relationship with AFC
first we agreed to after designing the
elements of the program with them agreed
to make 20 million dollars available in
capital that we would use to acquire
loans that AFC first originated that
were energy efficiency themed the
program elements that we agreed upon
were essentially the following um only
Energy Star rated or better
installations would be approved and by
the way I am aware the Energy Star has
got a bit of a black eye over the last
couple weeks but it's still the only
certification program that anyone
recognizes and I think on balance is
probably better than just nothing so but
but four years ago it was much better
than just nothing now they would just be
slightly better than just nothing but
anyway was mutt used to be much better
than just nothing so energy star
improvements or better okay 10-year
unsecured loans by the way that is a
term a length of time is essentially
unprecedented in this in this market
space but goes towards keeping the
monthly loan payment low enough so that
we meet the high concept I described
earlier $10,000 maximum and then we were
able to offer a rate that covered AFC's
spread
to do the servicing to run its network
to develop training materials and those
kinds of things and a yield at Treasury
deemed appropriate based on the factor
we were using as a comparable at that
time which was fed funds rate if i'm not
mistaken so in the first year of the
program the loans were at 799 now a lot
of people may say gee 709 isn't that
cheap i can do less with my home equity
line etc we basically said you know what
we think energy efficiency is a great
idea if you can do it for less please go
somewhere else and take that money if
you can do it with money you have in a
bank and do it in cash great do it if
you want to take out a home equity line
fine do it but there are thousands and
thousands of people every year who are
putting this on credit cards at eighteen
percent we're doing it through big-box
financing it at more than eighteen or
twenty percent we're not able to do it
at all and for these people and by the
way AFC was doing lots and lots of these
loans at twelve and fourteen percent
which is the basic market rate that we
were looking at that point so this is a
significantly below market rate and
yells yet still one that allowed
treasure to be a prudent investor okay
we flex the rates a little bit in the
following year because the national
interest rate market changed and we went
to 899 but they're fixed rate so once
you took out a loan that was the rage
that she got for the period of the loan
and the program was very well received
we had lots of transaction volume
essentially all that Treasury was
prepared to support at that time ran the
program for about two and a half three
years and in 2008 the state
environmental agency which kind of
doubles in Pennsylvania is the Energy
Office came to us and said just got some
funding from the legislature to support
consumer energy conservation we know
about your program and we'd like to see
if we could partner up so we work with
DEP change the terms so that we were now
actually bull what we call buying down
the rates below market so we're using
DEP dollars to offer the loans to
homeowners at 59 not mix new 699 59 and
499 explain what that is in a minute and
then would buy up Treasuries yield and
the amount that AFC needed to cover its
spread by using DEP program support dog
so we essentially combine a sustainable
model if you will with a publicly
supported model this allowed us as i
said to offer even lower rates and we
can build in
graduated or tiered structure the
created incentives so now the sort of
baseline rate of human of the 699 was
for people who did the traditional
energy star loans 599 were for people
who did equipments that actually cleaned
the top 10% more or less of the Energy
Star lists so now you're not just energy
star you got to be the best of the
energy star you're doing more you
probably paying a little more for
installation we can offer your better
rate the exciting thing we did was build
in whole house principles now to get to
499 rate you had to agree to do a whole
house audit by a certified auditor and
implement a minimum number of
recommendations off the auditors list
and you can get a 499 loan we push the
maximum at that point up to fifteen
thousand dollars and so in that fashion
we think we created this blend of
incentives and some market steering by
encouraging whole house practices
without resorting to a traditional
commanding control we didn't say we'll
only fund whole house audit loans but we
made it clear that those the ones that
we thought were best and the ones who
provide the greatest level support too
so program has now been in place for
about four and a half five years has
been but we think our standards a very
very significant success we've done more
than 5,500 loans starting from zero we
have 35 million dollars that we've put
out in loan product and currently
treasury is holding about 22 million
dollars that the rest is sort of paid
off either it's just it's been reduced
or some people paid early and even
though this program started before the
economic meltdown and we're now one
hopes coming out of the economic
meltdown we're looking at alone alone
loss experience of under one and a half
percent aggregate so we're we're very
pleased with that and it is a a straight
unsecured program so that performance is
is we think quite remarkable we actually
think that there are some and this is
entirely anecdotal if not arguably
preposterous but we think there's some
reason to believe that there's a
psychological connection that that folks
made when they
realize they put something in there's
actually benefiting them but they're
really very pleased about the product
had gotten none of these loans are
actually funded to the contractors until
the homeowner signs off and says yes
this was done to my specifications this
is what i ordered this is what i want so
we have a high level of buying at the
outset for a product that people think
is actually working for them we and we
believe it is working the anecdotal
information we have is that people are
saving money on their energy costs and
so the acceptance is quite significant
and so we are hoping that that's one of
the drivers that that's reflected in the
pay down performance to date now let me
try and I know we have brief time sewing
wrap up by talking about some concepts
of broader sustainability sort of
economic financial sustainability this
all sounds great and frankly it is great
I'm very very pleased about the program
even if the state energy money went away
and we had to return to our original
rate structure in theory that's a
sustainable program or a couple
generalizations I'm making here in
interest of brevity but in general
that's a sustainable program but there's
a problem being a prudent investor as we
have to be doesn't only mean that we
generate a return on what we invest in
it also means that we have to observe
principles about portfolio
diversification and consult end and
concentration that's a fancy way of
saying we can't hold too much of any one
kind of asset class at the end of the
day these loans wonderful as they have
been for us are still unsecured consumer
loans or as they're better known over
the last three years toxic okay and so
needless to say our financial people are
not ecstatic about having a lot of these
and so there's a limit to how much we
would hold how much paper would hold of
this kind of asset class and and I'm not
sure the financial people at Trader
who's seen this but we actually passed
that limit about three months ago and so
we can't really continue to do what
we're doing now we can't buy many more
of these loans after AFC first
originates them our sources are either
to abandon the program wait till loans
term out and we've got my money back
that's a long slow process or what's the
obvious solution we sell these exactly
we look for a secondary market investor
guess what these are a unique asset
class they don't exist other than here
okay there are no secondary market
investors for these kinds of loans all
right and if there were the first thing
they'd say is or these are unsecured
consumer loans thanks a lot and so
Treasury has now engaged upon a daring
emprise as we say to sell our portfolio
we retain an investment advisor we have
some very high level support from
foundations who are interested in our
sort of testing the marketplace we're
working with a consortium of other
states that want to see us develop a
model and a precedent and we hope within
the next three to six months to have
sold our portfolio and started to
establish a market value for these kinds
of loans now that's great but that's
still just Treasury that's just one sale
people have been paying attention to the
sort of national political climate on
this issue may be aware that the Obama
administration has essentially
identified home house retrofits as an
enormous not only opportunity but almost
essential undertaking for the country
and they're talking about millions of
homes or the next ten years being
retrofitted that could cost billions and
billions of dollars that would in theory
require a sustainable secondary market
not just Pennsylvania Treasury selling
25 million dollars every three or four
years that's not a sustainable secondary
market there are other states and in
fact utilities in other in other parts
of the country who are doing this to a
greater or lesser extent it turns out
and we didn't even realize this at the
time but it turns out that Treasury
Pennsylvania is doing something very few
if any one else is doing we are holding
our loans we are actually serving as our
own warehouse facility we can do that
because they're an asset class we're
happy about their performance virtually
everyone else is doing this cannot hold
their lolz so they're doing flow through
sales their bare originating loans and
they're selling them immediately because
there's they have to get rid of them
immediately there's only one buyer that
they can turn to fannie mae and fannie
mae currently buys these loans at 13 9 9
and 14 99 that's the yield that it
demands okay which is exorbitant and not
sustainable because no home
is going to take these loans out of that
you're not going to drive home owners to
get into this area at an interest rate
like that so states are having to buy
down or buy up depending on your
perspective to get Fannie Mae to do this
which means they're expending phenomenal
sums of money programs remain small so
there are other states would like to do
this the first step in those other
states being able to do that it do it is
to have a warehouse facility an
aggregator that could hold loans until
they reach a size that would attract
secondary market investors and then sell
them ok well Treasury's interested in
being such an aggregator and in a in a
sort of robust mature market you need
more than one we're talking about a lot
of money moving through but we need at
least one to start with so treasury is
also now working with advisors and the
Department of Energy to explore how to
model this market to determine whether
we can be a warehouse facility for these
loans which would allow other states be
doing it more robustly and far more
cheaply so let me sort of stop there
with that as the future for us we want
to keep doing this locally we want to
sell our portfolio and want to be able
to create at least the first what we
hope will be a series of warehouse
facilities that would enable more states
to do this in a way more or less similar
to not be identical more or less similar
to the way we are which fits in with a
lot of goals that we all have no thank
you i hope i didn't run too long thank
you Keith why don't we why don't we go
to to the town of babylon and then we'll
go back up to the state level afterwards
storian bruce we will send some of our
governance people here co-op board
judicial not expedite don't address that
I think we're pretty good at that well
ok we in the town of babylon first and
foremost and i think is critical
consideration have a real action bias we
have a real action bias because we got a
young turk who is the supervisor of the
town who's been a long time
environmentalist and who fundamentally
looks at problems and wants to solve
them immediately if not sooner so it's
usually damn the torpedoes as far
as far as we go and a good example of
that is we passed building codes in 2006
requiring Energy Star standards for home
construction and LEED standards for all
new commercial and industrial
construction over 4,000 square feet we
had a large developer named it
blumenfeld who is putting up a tanker
mall in our in our Township and at the
press conference he goes up to Ed and he
says pull them aside this is a press
conference with a groundbreaking for
this big mall and since up use he was a
dad I want to talk to you about green
and later ed says at a US Green Building
Council gala that he never in his life
had been shaken down so brazenly in such
a public way until the supervisor says
no no I want you to do this project
green and he was so relieved he said
sure and of course he didn't know what
he was getting into but he does
perceived a silver certification for his
project and the short term environmental
benefit was that they opened up a rail
spur to bring in all construction
material take out construction waste
eliminating all that diesel fuel traffic
coming in and out of the town I can
assure you that really reduce the ruffle
feathers we still had certainly a good
number of them and oh by the way there
was a examination of eight major
projects that started out a long island
since the year 2000 including a
lighthouse project and Nassau with a
large developer call rekla which is now
shelved and the last project to start
which was at tanger mall in 2005 was the
first and only project to finish so I I
say that yes by way of illustrating that
for one reason or another and I think
there are probably lots of contributory
factors I think we have been admirably
positioned to really get things done so
the next step we went to after we found
out that nobody was building anything
new and we couldn't save any we can
reduce our carbon footprint that way was
to figure out how to make our town
facilities more efficient and as that
was being done by enesco our supervisor
said now
let me hear this again you're going to
change out all our energy infrastructure
and the capital the savings that we
realize as a result of this changeover
is going to cover the capital cost and
you guarantee it and the esco said yep
and he says can you do that for
residential and the esco looked at them
like at three eyes and they said look
you know when we're doing one of these
large-scale jobs all we have to do is
deal with one slightly eccentric energy
director but when we're doing this on a
larger scale basis we're going to have
300 homeowners some of whom are ieds so
waiting to blow up on us and I can
assure you that there's a case and you
know there's a disaggregated cost it's
simply not an economic model first but
the one thing we knew in looking at this
particular business was that this esco
was bringing in sub cons to do the
actual work and they were taking a
30-percent management fee on top of it
so clearly there was a lot of fat to be
drawn upon in this process and
everybody's you know I think underscored
that since that's time I think you're
all quite familiar with the stats in our
town thirty-eight percent of our
residential thirty percent of our carbon
footprint is due to residential housing
and 24 to commercial so we have huge
opportunities and if like everybody else
we have these very aspirational goals to
reduce our carbon footprint clearly the
largest scale opportunity is in the
building sector so the first thing that
we set about doing was to figure out how
we might finance a pilot project in our
town we attracted an energy from waste
facility a couple of decades ago called
covanta you might have read an article
about energy from waste facilities on
the new york times last week it's in
Denmark I think they have 29 of them for
five and a half million people and the
United States we have 87 of them for 300
million people we're fortunate in
Babylon to be one of those facilities
and what it's meant in practical terms
is we've been generating 16 megawatts of
power and getting revenues from that we
up charging tipping fees from
surrounding municipalities and on top of
that at about the same time we wrenched
control of of the carding from the guys
in Brooklyn and so yeah which I talk so
they no longer get the Vig we get it and
so in fact we've turned a collection of
solid waste into a revenue stream for
the municipality and as a result we have
a large solid waste reserve and that's
where this pile of money was sitting it
was capturing very nominal money market
rates so all we had to do is figure out
how to rationalize our funding energy
waste from a solid waste facility so we
expanded our definition or the our
standard definition of solid wasting to
look it up I won't have to repeat it for
you but we added energy waste by dint of
its carbon component carbon dioxide
being twenty percent carbon ergo
Solomon's origins ergo good enough for
us to tap into this fund and we were off
to the races as far as that aspect of it
was concerned then we had to figure out
how we were to actually build this and
at the time there was a lot of buzz
about something called pays pays you
saved and there were a number of pilot
programs that have been run with
utilities nyserda who is the operational
energy unit in our state had done a
white paper and everybody had been a
party to how wonderful a principle this
was including our powers our authority
on Long Island but when we asked them if
they might do on-bill financing for us
they politely politely declined to do so
and as a result we then went back to our
own system and as we were billing waste
collection as a benefit assessment as we
do any any service that we provide
private entities we determined that that
would be the way we would bill and we
had a robust software system that did
our billing for us and as a result
almost unwittingly
we stumbled across what now is popularly
become to be referred to as pace
programs or property assessed clean
energy programs except ours is really a
base program it's a benefit assessed
clean energy program and I would suggest
that the strength of that is that it
doesn't have that four-letter word in it
tax it doesn't it has the same effect if
the homeowner is not selling their
obligation in a timely fashion and our
delinquent it does revolve to the
property tax to date we've had over 400
participants and hasn't been the case
we're not an operation as long as
Pennsylvania but it it also means that
we are using a mechanism that's been
well established and validated it was
affirmed by the revenue bond Act of 1933
and is a common municipal vehicle used
across the country in various ways
shapes and forms i know in pennsylvania
where there are commonwealth there are
more restraints constraints on
localities doing these kinds of
initiatives but we're we're a home rule
a state to a large degree although red
agarwalla the sustainability officer
from New York City might take issue with
how much latitude the state actually
affords them again the advantage of
being kind of a backwater as we are in
Babylon is that we've done things again
with this action bias that many people
might have subjected to question so when
a neighboring town went to emulate our
program and they're about twice our size
of town named Brookhaven their in-house
attorney said well this is a violation
of article 8 section 1 of the new york
state constitution which posits that a
public entity may not provide a loan or
a gift to a private entity unless it's
for a public purpose and these are loans
and we don't see any public purpose in
this well we took issue with that and
and part we were able to do that because
again getting back to the operational
aspects of why I think we've been able
to proceed expeditiously we have we take
our town attorneys and puts them in a
cage in the corner of town hall and only
let them out when they'll give us
validating opinions on what we want to
do she must be married to an attorney
the I think that again you also have to
look at what you're doing in a program
and think of the worst case scenario so
having been something of a student of
that Great Satan Robert Moses we know
that once you get something halfway done
and it's looking pretty good and it's
already halfway there it's going to take
a heck of a team of horses to hold it
back from getting completed and that's
really what we looked at when we went
operation with our program and people
questioning it we said okay what's going
on here somebody sees us what what what
are they suing well they're suing a
program that seals up people's houses or
maybe AC heirs saves homeowners money
puts people to work oh and by the way is
the revolving fluent we get our money
back that's pretty good policy and if
you want to sue us great that's great
press release will get more exposure for
it and frankly at the end of the day
that's the doughnut hole in all these
programs that I think we're still
tiptoeing around and that's how we're
actually going to drive demand after all
the smart money people collect and
identify how these ones get packaged
resold to cetera and so forth you know
there's an awful lot of interest but
that interest is we've seen over the
past 30 years has yet to even begin to
reach critical mass among the actual
people who will use these services and
that's the homeowner and that's why we
believe also what we've done in this
Babylon program is particularly
important we like to say that there are
three things that we're providing the
homeowner that's cost comfort and
convenience we are giving them a
one-stop retrofit we're providing their
financing at this point it's only three
percent we're going to have to ratchet
that up a little bit if we want to
you know patch disease won't simply sell
them so that's that's a nice attraction
obviously the benefits s loan if they
leave before the term of the obligation
the balance of the obligation gets
assigned to the property ergo the next
property owner picks it up and out on
the hook for you know X number of years
we also qualify all our contractors
they're all Building Performance
contractors and rather than you as a
single homeowner dealing with a home
improving contractor when he comes up
short on what you think he should be
doing you have the good auspices of the
entire town to bring down upon the
shoulders of set you know
underperforming contractor because
obviously if he's only dealing with you
he can go through small claims court and
you know make you wait forever but if
he's got dozens of jobs that he's
dependent on from the town he responds
very quickly and I can assure you that's
exactly what's happened in circumstances
where people have in fact had issues and
the other beauty is we're also running a
program and this is I don't know how
when was the last time you receive
services or products from somebody you
didn't like them and then in November
you actually got to step into a booth to
vote to fire the CEO of that operation
that's in effect what you get to do when
you have these municipal administered
operations so people ask us about the
cost of actually administering this and
we've just absorbed that into the cost
of doing town business we pick up your
garbage we clip shovel your streets we
fill your potholes and now we're sealing
up the cracks and crevices in your house
as a part of doing town business it
means that we also have decided program
discipline our average jobs are running
close to a 2-point osir say he's to
investment ratio so in effect and we've
already established that the savings do
cover the cost of the loans we also were
very vigorous in bringing in all the
stakeholders we brought in the unions we
brought in the contract
we brought in the local bankers and real
estate folks who might customarily have
objected and we got signed off so we
haven't had really anybody taking issue
the only challenges we've had are those
neighboring towns you know who've been
interested in the aspirational aspects
of doing these programs but somehow
can't get out of their way when they
actually get down to trying to figure
out how they are going to be go go
operational so this has been one of our
challenges because there are neighboring
towns who have been launching their
programs and then asking us for advice
but at the end of the day we really are
fortunate in the town that does stars
have aligned and we have a very
entrepreneurial spirit and a few capable
guys who are willing to actually you
know hit the ground running and get
things done a lot of other things I
could tell you but I think I'm gonna
pass it along Dorian thank you very much
no George oh by the way on the issue of
best practices we collect suboptimal
practices although although it's it's
really kind of a touchy issue because
while I'm one of the few people who
seems to get away with telling people
what's what most people really don't
like to hear it and and when you're
working for a politician he gets really
nervous when you do tell people these
things so thank you thanks well we're
switching from energy efficiency
investments to renewables here with I
guess the topic is feed-in tariffs and
I'm actually going to focus on what we
have which is a little difference called
a standard offer program basically as an
overview Vermont's been trying for in
the Vermont legislature in particular
been trying for a number of years to
encourage renewable energy development
when a number of other New England
states started pursuing renewable
portfolio standards Vermont looked at
and said gee that's a nice idea but
we're not sure we want to go that far
because it might raise costs for people
so eventually in 2005 we put in a system
we
there is a renewable portfolio standard
that doesn't take effect till 2013 but
the legislature decided to create a
carrot and stick the stick is there the
RPS the carrot piece was what was called
the speed program I always had to
remember what the this acronym means
sustainably priced energy enterprise
development program basically it's an
they set up a a program which says if
you can get me tall low growth in
Vermont with energy efficiency or
renewable and have at least five percent
renewables by 2012 over the 2004
baseline no RPS kicks in and and so the
incentive was out there for the
utilities to start developing renewables
and and everybody including the
Renewable community said gee this will
be enough you know now that will
actually start doing something in 2008
there was some development but a couple
of other things happen that basically
sort of changed everybody's mind set
number one energy efficiency really was
kicking in sir so we were expecting
we're having no low growth and actually
last year think loads down three percent
of course recession helped a lot on that
but even before that the energy
efficiency programs that are run in
Vermont now pretty much eliminate most
almost all low growth in the state and
beyond that some of the renewables that
had been developed early on in
particular by a couple utilities we're
going to cover the entire five percent
so the all the incentives in this
program didn't seem to be working to
have this wonderful spur of renewable
development and and and get a lot more
proposals out there you know we do have
in front of us or do we have approved at
the club of service board to wind
facilities but they they've gotten hung
up
financing issues and haven't been built
yet so in 2008 the legislature decided
to go a little farther and say okay
instead of having this incentive we want
the you public service board to develop
a rate for renewable projects that will
encourage them but still maintain be
consistent with least cost principles
given the most renewable development is
more costly than then other alternatives
huntin market that was a little bit of a
challenge we looked at that for a little
bit and given that they passed the bill
in the middle of the year by January
they are already in patient that we
didn't have tons of development so they
took the whole thing out of the public
service boards hands and set up the
standard offer program and and let me
just state that the standardized we
think it's an important distinction
between a standard offer and feed-in
tariff it's not a tariff per se one
thing to keep in mind i'm going to put
my lawyer hat on is that the tariffs for
wholesale services and these are
wholesale products are regulated at the
federal level so if the state wanted to
actually do the tariff we couldn't
because it becomes a state tariffs and
you know it would be an attempted to
state Harrop but it wouldn't be our
jurisdiction so we couldn't do it and
then the utilities would actually be the
one that's going to FERC and if they
didn't actually want to do it our
leverage to make him do anything was
fairly limited the standard offer
program by contrast makes use of the
state essentially buying the power and
distributing it to all the other
utilities we have an entity called the
speed facilitator who was put in place
when the whole program was first put
gotten up and running in 2005 his goal
originally was to try to
go out and make deals and encourage
deals between the renewable developers
and utilities and didn't really produce
much but his role was expanded by the
legislature to now offering these
standard offer contracts the the
legislature thought that also got around
the jurisdictional problems there's an
open question there there certainly some
questions as to whether we in fact are
engaging in wholesale operations but
nobody's raised that so far and it's
part of the standard offer program what
the legislature directed us to do was to
have a 50 megawatt program for small
small renewable development maximum size
2.2 megawatts have it have program thus
offers available until that that 50
megawatts was filled and we were
supposed to set rates based upon cost
the rates that we offered by the speed
facilitator were based upon cost not
least cost principles and so if the cost
of a solar project was at least get to
the prices in a minute it was thirty
cents we're supposed to send set a rate
of thirty cents per kilowatt hour for
that solar project even though the
market price at the time the bill passed
was somewhere around seven cents and now
is believed in New England's around four
and a half cents is the market clearing
price so you can see see a major gap
here in terms of what we're paying under
this program and what the alternatives
are in the market the other part of this
is this be facilitator who is under
contract to us the public service board
and for those of you who we have a
different name every most other states
call it the Public Utilities Commission
same thing there are some different
splits in Vermont that make it different
but we're the equivalent of the Public
Utilities Commission
in most other states the speed
facilitator works for us and he buys the
power and then distributes it to all the
other utilities so it gets shared among
all the other utilities so that dick
that gets around the issue of well this
utility doesn't want to buy these solar
projects because it's going to raise its
rates everybody in its it's essentially
a public benefit of a public sharing
type program so in terms of pricing in
order to encourage this what what the
statute requires is that we said set the
prices that the program will pay based
upon the cost so we look at costs both
direct install cost operation
maintenance costs financing costs you
may have to make assumptions on what's
it going to cost the finance and and we
actually had to litigated case where we
heard evidence on on all these things
which was fairly entertaining you
include a reasonable return on the
investment built into that and then you
make adjustments for you known revenue
streams that they're going to have such
as grants and in the end you make a
final adjustment which is enough to
encourage rapid development but not too
much which some people came to start
calling the Goldilocks standard it's not
clear exactly what that meant it
basically gave us discretion to to to
adjust the rates up and down and this
took effect last June June of 2009 what
the legislature also did was told us we
had to have the program up and running
by September by the end of September so
they gave us a grand total of three
months to get this whole new program up
and running we missed the date by a
little bit we got got the first bids in
and first proposals in in October is
when we open the program up they do set
in the statute default prices the
default prices 30 cents per kilowatt
hour for solar
when he sends for small wind and wind
15-kilowatt Celeste 12 cents for
landfill methane and 12 and a half cents
for other renewable sources and said
those prices are going to be in the
initial prices unless you bored by
mid-september in three months tell it
you know to find that they're completely
wrong and in three months we had time to
look enough to say now they're in there
at least in the ballpark except we
raised the farm methane price from 12
and a half to 16 cents following that we
were required to have a detailed
evaluation of the prices and actually
set them bottom up by january fifteenth
we met that deadline the result of that
was the solar drop from 3224 all the
prices all the prices came down a little
bit farm methane from 16 to 14.1
landfill methane down to 9 and the rest
are somewhere right around 12 cents per
kilowatt hour again the markets still
four and a half cents the the program
was opened the results of the program it
was opened up in october nine teams
that's when we opened it for bids on the
first day the program was open we had
bids for 47 megawatts of power actually
we had bids for 160 megawatts but we had
set up sub caps so that no one
technology could be more than 12 and 12
and a half megawatts because we had some
suspicions that solar was going to flood
flood the system and in fact we got 185
bids for solar for somewhere around 169
megawatts I think most of us looked at
those numbers and said gee I think we
got the solar price a little too high
with with that kind of demand
but the whole program 47 megawatts
within the sub caps filled on the first
day within two weeks we had filled the
whole 50 megawatts of the program the
average size it was nearly 1 megawatt
each so these are some with the two and
a half or 2.2 megawatt cap these are
more sizable facilities there they're
not to know your homeowner size or farm
size developments for the most part
these are these are much larger except
obviously the farm methane programs
which are farm size the the projects are
now working their way through the
approval process and some are actually
up and running some of those are going
to drop out we know we know they're
going to drop out they're not going to
get financing and then we'll have to
deal with who moves into the program but
so far I think the effect of the higher
prices has achieved with the legislature
wanted the flip side is the estimate to
that we heard during during our
proceeding is that it's going to be a
net incremental cost to ratepayers 252
million dollars over the next 20 years
small numbers but you know for those of
you in states that are bigger than
Vermont which is pretty much everybody
those are really small dollars but in
Vermont that's not an not an in
substantial amount that's a it's a
pretty good above market premium that
you're paying and that's the ultimate
bennett you know ultimate trade-off is
when they start flowing flowing through
into electrical rates what are people
going to say it's one of the one of the
big conundrums i think everybody with
renewable energy faces is us people they
want it yep how much more than willing
to pay
it gets a little fuzzier and we'll see
what the effect is it'll you know it'll
be several years before the effect
starts flowing through into rate so you
know get filtered in slowly but then
we'll see what happens so I'll stop
there great thank you one thing I was
remiss in mentioning and I'm going to
read this before we go into QA the event
sessions and their QA will be video
recorded by yael with the intent of
posting to youtube for public viewing
and by participating in the QA audience
members acknowledge that their questions
will be included so Thank You panelists
I thought that was excellent up I think
we're fortunate to hear about
experiences that are perhaps more than
just first-generation communities and
states that are that have been at this
for some time and I think are perhaps
suggesting some areas of interest in
questions questions around whether
there's sufficient demand to to bring
these to scale questions of what what it
might take to get a secondary market
built around these products and why
don't we why don't we turn it over to
all of you for for questions and
discussion
anyone wait we've answered every
question okay not preempted because
every I just over on the side here
Thanks hi my name is Kristen trots and I
am a second year at the Yale School of
Forestry and I'm curious it sounds in
each of your experiences that you had a
active role played by the legislature or
the equivalent body and in your
situation and I'm curious if if you
believe that there are drivers for
programs like these in places where
there's not state support are there are
there other drivers that can lead to the
establishment of these types of programs
that are not wholly backed by the state
well you're the state guys I could tell
you that that's my biases to be as
independent as possible we you know we
developed our program in the Sahara the
debt of the Bush years and I think the
self-reliance that we had to instill in
our program has made it a stronger
program we are continuing as we've done
from the outset belinta market-based
solutions and get away from as much no
government input as possible we will
leave others to go through the process
where we're sort of again as I've
animated less process oriented than that
and there plenty of people who are
willing to carry the water on that we
just prefer to get the job done so you
know we'll continue to look for partners
and four mechanisms that will enhance
that principle and just for more from my
perspective and I think from I can speak
from the state's our state's perspective
the Legislature's role in this one was
key but that was not not so much an
absence of willingness to go forward as
we're a creature of state law and we
have to comply with state law and
everything we do and what some of the
principles that have been embedded in
state law for years our principal such
as least cost provision of energy
service and we fall to utilities when
they enter into contracts that aren't at
least cost when you stand for something
like a renewable standard and when
you're going to pay somebody 30 cents or
24 cents per kilowatt hour for solar
when you can buy it for four and a half
cents if utility had done that before
this statute we probably would have said
gee that's not warranted now but that
that having been said for years we've
pushed the envelope to take into account
non monetary cost considerations as we
call them externalities and we've hadded
externality adjustments for 20 years in
Vermont taking into account environment
unpriced externalities such as air
emissions I'm not sure we fully captured
the FGM probably reasonably certain that
in some of those we haven't fully
captured the value of carbon and climate
change that's that's a very tough but
but certainly we take that into account
for you know so for example we've
approved one utility paying an extra six
cents for solar for solar before this
because it was likely to be on on peak
and because it was on on peak it
actually had a different cost
characteristic than
normal market purchase and it was more
likely to be cost effective so we've
pushed the envelope but we're stuck with
complying with state law which has the
least cost principles which is
ratepayers by the way most of us want we
don't want to play for gold plated
facilities so therefore the
Legislature's role was absolutely key in
telling us to either abandon those
principles or exactly what to do because
otherwise we not being complying with
our duties I'm gave to Bosh the yellow
school management you touched very
slightly on sort of the idea of base
bonds or base spawns as you call them
and actually the Jacka dahi who I
believe was was involved in coming up
with the original idea behind based
bonds presented presented the idea at
the school management just just a month
ago the name was Jack Hadari Oh jacket
here we go yeah so he's it seemed I
think to everyone there there's a really
elegant idea and it and it sort of dealt
with a lot of the the principal-agent
issues that you see in investment to the
sort I'm wondering from your perspective
or frankly any one's perspective here
what the what some of the challenges are
being adopted on a much wider scale yeah
sure I mean I'll very briefly say we
have obviously not had to deal with that
we developed a model that is working
with no security we understand the
appeal of that the challenge that we see
in that is you need to get many many
municipalities to each implement such a
program and you have to work through
whether municipalities have the
resources to be generating revenue
streams others getting into capital
markets that's something that most
smaller municipalities are going to be
challenged to do I think you also have
to then get them to put together the
infrastructure to start including the
additional building component and the
collection associated with that and then
I suppose the other issue is whether
municipalities when push comes to shove
and I don't want to sound like I'm
opposed to playing gov
advocate what municipalities are going
to start foreclosing on properties
because someone's not paying thirty five
dollars a month towards their energy
costs in which case at which point is it
any more secure than an unsecured loan
and having to put it off a lot of
process around something that doesn't
provide any additional security for the
investment good good so I think I also
we also view it as a pretty promising
mechanism I think there are a few areas
of concern for for us that we and our
PRC I think one of them is that these
are voluntary programs so the
proposition has to be clear enough and
compelling enough for a property owner
to you know to take that lead and it's
not clear to us yet that there you know
that this has been socialized
sufficiently that there is enough you
know demand to get get to scale but
there's a lot of effort I think underway
by many groups to to make that happen I
think there's a lot of discussion about
the tension between the lien and the
mortgage holder in terms of what happens
in a stress case what happens in a
foreclosure and and the implications for
mortgage holders in terms of where they
fall in line in terms of the flow of
payments and and I think related to that
which is interesting is that I think the
information there's a there's an
information disparity in terms of the
information about the lean and how the
financial community sees it and it's
available to them and information around
cost savings and I think today if you're
a mortgage broker looking at the
refinancing of a property and that
property has a pace lean on it you only
see the lien you don't you don't see the
cost savings that's associated with it
and and frankly you might not even be
aware of you know what what what the
mechanism is so I think in general I
think there's a lot of for lack of a
better word socializing around the
concept that needs to take place but I
think there's there's there are many
reasons a compelling reasons to make
that happen and lots
groups that I think are active in trying
to you know to overcome these hurdles
you just jump on that last part for one
second the interesting thing is that
that's the exact same obstacle that the
people have been pushing for energy
efficient energy efficient mortgages
have been unable to overcome for
probably a decade and a half now the
fact that that they want the reduction
in household operating expenses
associated with a much tighter house to
be reflected in the borrower's FICO
score and and banks and lenders will
have not yet agreed to do that so all
they see is that the house cost twenty
thousand dollars more to make it real
tight they don't see that it returns two
thousand dollars less and annual costs
associated with the savings from that so
if this is that in particular that's
that's an existing problem that no one's
solved yet I'm sorry me too no no no no
I think that's a great point you look up
there's 17 states that have passed the
worst kinds of pace legislation to date
it's probably aware because it seems
like in the following this and you know
I know in New York there was
quote-unquote pace legislation passed in
November that had been pushed by
actually our congressmen but it was
really contingent on a lot of other
enabling bits of legislation
particularly the federal level so you
don't have those kind of price supports
for example that are elemental to them
we actually had legislation in all
fairness I to this young lady's question
before our local Assemblyman and state
senator had gotten legislation to
actually affirm the principle that we
have using a waste district to do waste
reduction so in effect in New York State
you if you either have a waste district
which many people may miss colonies do
you can do this or if you want to you
can create a waste district you do this
kind of work and in fact that gives you
the validation to then go out and do
various kinds of financing as far as
bonding is concerned again you know it
gets back to you know what kind of rates
are you getting is this the ideal
vehicle at this particular point in time
for this particular application what
when we're looking at now there were
bought a larger numbers and the
the financial guides by the way we were
the first ones to tell us when they when
we created this unwittingly I must say
an all-new difference to Jack Henry the
wonderful guy you know success has a
hundred fathers and I would success i
would suggest this case program has a
maybe a thousand father's circling
around it right now but we unwittingly
as i said developed this same principle
without knowing what the acronym was
ultimately going to be and we only found
out how good it was when you know the
big-money guys like Bruce came talking
to us because we wanted to move to a
market based model and they said you
know we're more than eager to get behind
you on this but you got to have at least
30 million aggregated can you guys can
you guys figure out how to go through
neighborhoods the same way you like
repave roads and get like a hundred
houses at a time doing it on the same
day and we just looked at him cross-eyed
but the principle is yes we have to get
to know these aggregated levels before
you know those kinds of principles kick
in but for us at the point in time where
we are based upon the other programs
that are developing around us we're
going to actually bond for two million
two million but we're going to use that
as a loan loss reserve to then attract a
debt and equity capital that's that's
the principle we're going to be pursuing
and we're not going to be funding this
entirely out of government bonds and so
and so forth I just don't think that's a
long-term sustainable solution the
partnership is a key and figuring that
one out okay so Leslie just oh can we
have time for one more question she
brought in are you hooking us up well
one more question okay thank you a quick
a very quick question please like
I question for you mr. Woltz about the
program that you were describing and
just that sounds like there's a
disconnect between the rate of return
that's acceptable to the Commonwealth
and what's acceptable in the market this
eight percent or nine percent that's
that you're willing to you know to take
and then the market is demanding 14 or
for 12 or 14 or whatever the percentages
how do you see like these how do you see
your this program moving forward you
know how do you how are you going to be
able to sell these these loans with that
disconnect are you going to be have to
take a well other Matt discounter
essentially what your let's accept your
statement of the facts that there's some
things I could constrain up its height
it's a fair read of what I said and we
don't need to clarify that what you're
really describing is a monopoly
situation right now given that there's
no one else able to aggregate the only
place these loans are able to go in a
flow-through basis is fannie mae fannie
mae therefore as a monopoly control and
is essentially demanding the yield that
it's able to demand so the goal of
creating a secondary market which i
talked about at the very end of my
remarks is in fact to create
alternatives to fannie mae at much lower
rates if we can demonstrate that these
loans perform and when an address
investors concerns about security
perhaps by adding a paste component or a
non bill payment component or any of the
other things and generate a yield of
seven or eight percent then investors
may be willing to take them out at seven
or eight percent and then Fannie Mae has
to either stop doing it or become more
competitive so you're absolutely right
that is exactly the problem that's that
that is represented by the absence of a
secondary market and that's we're hoping
to address is that responsive so join me
in thanking our panelists both for being
here today and for their leadership
you